[Music]
[Music]
investigative journalist philip sheenan
explores the history of the 911
commission in the commission the
uncensored history of the 9 11
investigation
mr sheenan recounts the research and
drafting of the 9 11 commission report
and profiles the commission's members
including its chairman tom kane vice
chairman lee hamilton and executive
director philip zeliko
mr sheenan reports that mr zeliko's
former ties with the bush administration
gave the appearance of a potential
conflict of interest throughout the
investigation
philip sheenan discusses his book with
michael duffy assistant managing editor
time magazine
[Music]
welcome to afterwards i'm michael duffy
of time magazine and our guest today is
phil sheenan of the new york times a
veteran reporter for the newspaper and
the author of a new book the commission
the uncensored history of the 9 11
investigation
welcome thank you very much great to
have you here thanks the commission is a
fascinating book a very highly readable
account of the special panel that was
put together after the 9 11 attacks to
investigate what happened why it
happened and what could be done
differently in the future
it's also a controversial book for a
raid along its spine is the strong
suggestion that various things according
to some people
possibly were left out of the 911
commission so we'll talk about that
today too the author is here to talk
with us today uh but before we start i
thought i'd say welcome and i don't
think we've ever met before today i'm
surprised that that's the case it's a
small city it is a small city uh phil
sheenan was born and raised in san
francisco uh he's 48 years old he's
worked at the new york times since 1981
which is a very long time uh he in that
time he has covered the state department
the justice department
congress just about everything the
pentagon he's worked overseas for the
times in southeast asia and the middle
east and he's currently one of the
newspapers investigative reporters
he lives in washington d.c and
this book is a great read and i wanted
to start by asking just
what gave you the idea for the book phil
well i was the lead reporter for the
times covering the commission for the
whole life of the commission from
december 2002 right through the final
report in july 2004 and i had a ringside
seat for what was the equivalent for our
generation of the warren commission the
great investigation of our time and it
occurred to me that there were parts of
the story that i wasn't learning i i had
no access to the staff the people who
actually did the digging
during the course of the investigation
those people were suddenly available to
me after the commission went out of
business and they had some remarkable
stories to tell
uh and i also think uh at the time most
reporters who were covering the
commission
sort of waited for the commission to do
its work there were some hearings and
there were some obviously some reports
at the beginning of the hearings but
mostly it was not a um a transparent
outfit correct no no that's absolutely
true and really
during the same period the nation was
going to war in iraq so there was a much
bigger story to cover in washington and
really for for the first six months of
the investigation we heard almost
nothing from the commission now over
time the commissioners themselves the 10
members became very available to us to
talk but again the real diggers the stat
the investigators just weren't weren't
there for us now remind us a little bit
it's been a few years what the
commission why the commission was
founded and what in brief it did fine
uh it was founded really at the
insistence of the 9 11 families and of
senator john mccain they really came
together to to force the white house and
congressional republicans to have an
independent investigation of wha of what
had gone so wrong before 9 11. how is it
possible that this attack could have
taken place um and
the central finding was that there was
enormous disarray within the federal
government in dealing with terrorist
threats that the
there were dots out there but they
weren't being connected now the white
house as you mentioned opposed the
creation of this commission
for months now how long was that sort of
pushback and and why were they opposed
to its creation well they pushed back
for many months for the better part of a
year or much more than a year actually
and their argument was that listen we
cannot divert the central intelligence
agency in the fbi from their central
mission which is preventing another 911
we can't force them to answer the
questions of an independent
investigation at a time when they really
need to focus their attention elsewhere
and i suppose there's legitimacy to that
argument but obviously and i've got
people acknowledging this in the book
from the white house that there was a
terrible political fear of the
commission that it could do great damage
to president bush and condoleezza rice
and others at a time when the president
was planning his re-election campaign
why after nearly a year did the white
house finally capitulate and agree to uh
permit the creation of of the panel i
don't think it's it's too much to use
the word shame they they were shamed
into it by the families the families
mounted a a remarkable lobbying effort
remarkable if only because these people
had no background in how washington
works and they forced they forced the
white house and the and the
and the congressional republicans to
give in and again senator mccain was a
big part of that effort right i wanted
to ask you about that it was one of my
things to to put on the list here and
that is i do recall him breaking the log
jam
in a way the republican party had been
opposed in lockstep
was he as pivotal as i recall absolutely
absolutely now you know his uh his
friends and uh even some of his enemies
will tell you that what was going on
here was that the john mccain was was
seeking some revenge against people at
the white house that he was he was uh he
felt betrayed by george bush and by karl
rove and then their actions during the
2000 presidential election and he wanted
to to help to hold them to account for
what they may have done wrong uh in the
run-up to 9 11. and he of course argues
that you need an independent
investigation of a national tragedy like
this and at the end of the day working
with the families he was able to force
the creation of the commission now uh
for the two commission chairmen uh tom
kane and lee hamilton uh we learned in
the book that these were not the first
choices of of either side uh and uh
neither was uh particularly trying to
get it tell us a little bit about how we
ended up with those two uh people in
charge well the white house initially
chose henry kissinger to run the the
commission uh he was a controversial
choice because it was believed that he
was very close to the bush white house
that he might somehow protect the
president in this process and of course
he runs an international consulting firm
that has clients
all around the world that might not be
terribly interested in getting to the
bottom of al qaeda fundraising and 911
especially energy companies that he may
represent
the initial choice from the democrats
was senator george mitchell a very well
respected very partisan very smart man
and the belief on the part of democrats
was that he would be kissinger's equal
he would be this would be the kissinger
mitchell commission
and it might be quite a partisan battle
between the two of them both of them
step out of the scene quite early on
just within a few weeks kissinger uh
shortly after a showdown with some of
the 911 families uh mitchell because
he's new to his law firm it feels he
can't give up his uh his paycheck
essentially uh and they're replaced by
tom kane the very well-respected
former governor of new jersey a man
without great experience really no
experience in washington and no
experience in some of the issues before
the investigation but again hugely
respected by people
from both parties and lee hamilton it's
in many ways the the the democratic
equivalent of somebody like tom kane
hugely respected by both democrats and
republicans and one of washington's real
wise men on national security issues now
one of the things that you make clear in
the commission
the book i should say otherwise is that
canon hamilton from the beginning wanted
to find out what happened but they also
had seemed to make a strategic decision
at the start
not to point fingers of blame at people
in our government have i got that right
and why was that absolutely
i think they came to the decision early
on that that was just a non-starter if
they started pointing fingers it would
set republicans on the commission
against democrats and democrats against
republicans they'd never get a unanimous
report so the decision was made we are
not in the finger-pointing business
we're not going to have personal
accountability here is uh when all this
was happening as this investigation gets
underway really in late 2002 and the
beginning of 2003
uh there was a lot of other stuff going
on on in the country at that time that
was both about foreign policy and very
partisan and um and it's hard to to
really recreate that feeling at the time
but talk a little bit about um how the
rest of what was going on in washington
affects the context of the commission's
work just briefly particularly the
run-up to the iraq war this this was
about as part of the time as we'd known
in the city um uh it's remarkable i
think it could be any more partisan than
it is now but it was a
sharply partisan period especially with
the knowledge that a presidential
election was coming up congressional
elections were coming up you know these
fi the the members of the commission
were chosen by the most partisan members
of their party uh you know tom kane i i
have early on saying that he thought
this was a commission that was destined
to fail that there was no way they were
going to make this work in such a
partisan time and uh
do as you look back on it do some of the
members you talk to feel that it uh that
it was share that feeling that it was a
almost a uh i don't want to say suicide
mission but almost an impossible task or
did they feel that this was something
that was probably going to work out as
they began
i think more deformed they thought it
was an impossible task now a dominant
desk hand in the book perhaps the
dominant desk can uh is not so much the
choice of the different commissioners on
the book but the choice of the man who
ran the commission uh a nan named phil
zeliko he was it's i think it's chief of
staff but his exact title was executive
director executive director um tell us
about him and how he came to be chosen
he's a fascinating character he is a a
very well respected historian at the
university of virginia uh he runs a he
did run a presidential history project
there
um again i
few people i've ever met in washington
are so uniformly described as brilliant
by others who know him uh he early on is
is uh his name is thrown into the mix
for executive director of the 911
commission uh you know it's a polite
fiction in washington the blue ribbon
commission reports are written by the
blue ribbon commissioners that's almost
never the case they're usually written
by a professional staff often
congressional researchers or scholars
and that was certainly the case with the
911 commission it had an executive
director eventually philip zeliko is
chosen for that post and 85 other
staffers and they do most of the digging
and they do most of the riding
zelika was hired even though he has ties
throughout the bush administration
he is very friendly with somebody who's
right at the heart of the investigation
condolees arise and and that is known to
kane and hamilton when they signed him
on and
just what was zelico's role uh uh as an
adviser to condoleezza rice during the
transition film well if you let's
backtrack a little they had been friends
at the national security council in bush
41 in the in the first bush presidency
when uh
the incumbent president bush comes to
office in 2001 he sets a transition team
for the white house his new national
security advisor is condoleezza rice
and she picks her old friend philip
zeliko to run
to be involved in her transition team
for the national security council
and many of us didn't realize it until
much later on in the investigation but
zelico's role on the transition had been
specifically to review the operations of
the counter-terrorism group within the
nsc run by a man who would become very
famous later on by the name of richard
clark
and what we learned later much later on
in the 911 commission investigation is
that zelico had recommended
effectively that clark be demoted that
his whole team be uh
removed from instant access to the oval
office which they had enjoyed in the in
the uh in the presidency of bill clinton
right and uh the transit did zelico
actually write a report that stated that
i think there are memos i've not seen
them i assume they're highly classified
but and and
one of the things that uh is important
to know also is that uh as between the
time the transition ended
and the time the 911 commission uh
actually gets underway
um you report in the book uh that uh
zelico played another role uh for
condoleezza rice at the national
security in terms of drafting um a
particularly important memo well again
this is something i don't think many of
us who covered the commission understood
until much later and i think many of the
staff members didn't understand either
but zelico was the author of a very
important document issued by the white
house in september 2002 that really
turned military doctrine on its head and
said that the united states could become
involved in preemptive war preemptive
defense that we could attack a nation
that didn't pose an immediate military
threat to this country and obviously in
september 2002 it sure appeared that
that document was being written with one
target in mind iraq
now as i say the the author of the
document at the time was anonymous we
didn't know that philip zeliko had
written this thing
and that becomes known i think widely on
the staff only in the final months of
the 9 11 commission investigation and it
appeared to pose yet another conflict of
interest for zelico
just to be clear the the preemptive uh
doctrine remember comes out in september
of 2002 the commission is created
formally in december 2002 and duquesne
and hamilton when they hire zelico are
they aware of his uh are they aware of
his role as the author of the preemptive
doctrine i don't believe so when did the
administration actually make that uh
public order i think in september 2002.
oh so it was known then i said gotcha
they weren't aware
one of the
big hunks of the book uh that is
striking is that as the work gets
underway for the commission
zelico is particularly interested in one
aspect of its fairly complicated uh
probe which is across the government
what what interests him most well we
should say that he establi he hires most
of the investigators and he hires a
terrific bunch of people by and large
and many of them are democrats and you
know zelico has to be credited for
putting in place a lot of very
independent-minded scholars to do a lot
of this work from both parties from both
parties and both administrations i think
yeah he chose
people who are from the clinton
administration he puts in these in these
positions so i think that's a charge of
conflict of interest that may not be
appropriate for dr zelika uh but he does
he said one team in particular has his
attention and it is known as team three
uh and it is the team that investigates
counter-terrorism policy and it is the
team that has sort of the essential the
most important question before it which
is um or at least one of the most
important questions which is who's
telling the truth um condoleezza rice or
richard clark
was the bush white house in the spring
and summer of 2001 responding quickly
and appropriately to terrorist threats
as ms rice kept insisting or had they
ignored them as as dick clark kept
insisting and zelico did seem to take a
particular interest in the work of that
team talk a little bit before we go on
to some of the other things about about
this clark rice business because um for
those of us who are covering terrorism
at the tail end of the 1990s when
clinton was in office and the beginning
of the of the uh the next decade
there was a change in the way uh the
white house uh prioritized terror in in
the sort of ranking of foreign policy
challenges uh at in the nsc talk to us a
little bit about how that uh changed
because it gets to the question of
clark's role a bit well but clark it is
remarkable if you look through some of
the documentation during the bush
administration um whatever you can
certainly level criticism at the bush
administration for the well for the way
it dealt with terrorism it didn't end
the bin laden threat even though it had
eight years to do it but the fact that
the clinton administration i'm sorry
yeah the clinton administration uh
and uh you know
dick clark during that time period when
he was the counterterrorism adviser to
the national security council then sandy
berger and the president had almost
instant access to the oval office and
his uh his warnings about al qaeda were
delivered almost directly to the
president's desk
when the bush administration comes in it
appears they have a very different view
of the world and they have a very
different set of priorities most of them
dealing with sort of great power
questions between the united states and
russia and china missile defense
rogue states like iraq and north korea
and iran and terrorism seems to become
certainly from the documentary records
becomes a very much a secondary priority
for them and again what we know is that
apparently dr zeliko's urging dick clark
is effectively demoted that his his
issues do not receive the sort of
attention in the bush administration
they had received in the clinton
administration we're talking about the
commission the uncensored history of the
9 11 investigation a new book by phil
shannon
i want to go on and talk about uh two of
the agencies that really were at the
center for a lot of people uh uh of what
happened before uh 911 and and what
happened afterward um
the fbi and the cia probably were tagged
more than any other of the federal
agencies for dropping the ball in
different ways um and yet they took very
two very different approaches uh the two
agencies which are both very political
took very different approaches in
dealing with the commission when it
finally got organized and started taking
testimony um how were they different
let's do the one by one the fbi which in
many ways has more to answer for i think
than any other agency of government for
what went wrong before 9 11. i i think
if you ask the staff they will tell you
that perhaps the fbi more than any other
agency can can take the blame for 9 11.
uh yet it decided it's it being its
director robert mueller its new director
robert mueller decided he was going to
be he was going to mount a charm
offensive with the 911 commission he was
going to be in their faces literally
giving them every ounce of help they
needed every document they needed and
they really won over the commissioners
now bob mueller was new to the scene
he'd only taken the job at the fbi a
week before 9 11. so he couldn't really
take the blame he couldn't personally
take the blame for what had gone wrong
and all he wanted to do was apologize
and say he was going to make things
better
and he really wowed them by comparison
the cia
which in many ways was has a much better
record before 9 11 than the fbi uh took
a different tact which was that it
wasn't going to apologize in the same
way and its uh director was george tenet
who had been in place on 9 11 and who
had been in place for a very long time
and had a lot of sort of personal
accountability issues to to answer for
before the 9 11 commission and one other
problem is that the 911 commission
became quite convinced over time that
the tenant was having a great deal of
trouble telling the full truth and the
perception that the director of central
intelligence wasn't telling them the
truth added to the concern that
something really had gone wrong at the
cia now why do you think in a more
personal vein why do you think mueller
and tenet went in such different
directions in
in in guiding their agencies and their
dealings with
with with the commission this is it
would it would turn out to have an
enormous impact which we can get to in a
minute but but the two men why why were
their approaches so different ones so
resistant ones so um apparently uh
trying to be cooperative well get for
mueller he he's apologizing for acts he
didn't he's not responsible for it's a
whole lot easier for him to say listen
i'm sorry this happened because he
wasn't involved in the bad decision
making before 9 11. and mueller who was
you know it's remarkable how shy bob
mueller is we don't see much of him on
the scene in washington but apparently
behind the scenes he he is charming and
he is very effective as a lobbyist and i
think over the last seven years he's
managed to deflect an awful lot of blame
from the fbi that it to this day
deserves
the cia i think george tenet felt sort
of
he felt defensive about his own actions
he felt defensive about the agency's
actions at a time when he was running
the agency
and i think to
even perversely george tenet took huge
pride
over the cia's record at a time when the
commission wanted to blame the cia you
had to sort of disconnect between george
tenet saying we did a terrific job and
the commission saying well it doesn't
appear you did a terrific job because we
just had this monumental terrorist
attack tenant's a very interesting
character in the drama and and has been
uh you know before the commission and
after the commission he's written his
own book um one of the things you made
clear in the in in in the reporting is
that um the commission which was again
made up of democrats and republicans
came to not believe tenet um to be
credible uh when he would come up to
testify you make it clear that he forgot
key things that there were things that
he could not remember doing that he
would eventually recall in his memoirs
um
uh
i'm a little uncertain as to what what
the explanation for that is and i
suspect you are too but is there a is
there a uh
a best guess you can make about why his
performance in front of the commission
was more ragged
you know there there i've certainly
heard the allegation made that george
tenon is representative of a certain
clientitis he he wants to make the
person in front of him feel good he
wants the person in front of him
he wants to give the answers to the
person in front of him that they want to
hear and if he wasn't able to do that
then it appears according to the
commission staff that his memory would
fail him that
at those moments he couldn't review
remember key documents or key meetings
or or key interactions things he
absolutely should have been able to
remember
um
now the clintons were not exempt from
this probing although we've talked a bit
about what happened during the bush
administration um what did the
commission learn in general about uh the
role that uh president clinton had
played before he left office in terms of
taking al qaeda down and what didn't
they learn i think the belief on the
staff and certainly some of the
commissioners including some of the
republicans who were wary of giving
praise to bill clinton in the beginning
was that now bill clinton did want to
see osama bin laden dead he was ruthless
about it
and the cia some of the folks at the cia
were quite impressed with his
willingness to
essentially assassinate osama bin laden
but they were surprised to discover that
many people around the president were
much more reluctant much more frightened
at the prospect and george tended in
particular that the cia would come up
with capture or kill operations for bin
laden and mysteriously these uh these
these these projects would disappear
from the screen and it had much to do
they lane they'd learn later with george
tennant calling off the operations than
bill clinton well at the core of the
clinton uh the discussion in the book
and what he was able to do or not able
to do there was some uh some clear
confusion that the commission had about
whether clinton had it at some point
ordered uh issued a kill order on bin
laden in the late 1990s there was some
suggestion that he had not uh uh the
record eventually made clear that he had
but the that kill order um came with a
footnote it's uh and that can you spell
out why what that footnote was and what
that distinction about who was going to
be doing um
yeah well again i must admit i'm still
have some confusion about it to this day
but it does appear that in december 1998
on christmas eve
bill clinton essentially signed osama
bin laden's death warrant he said you
can kill him if you need to
now
over the course of the 911 commission
investigation the cia folks kept saying
no no we never got an explicit kill
order for for bidlot we got sort of
waffled you know legalese about maybe we
could kill him if we couldn't capture
him we never understood what we were
talking about but the clinton people
said no no no keep digging you'll find
this document if you do and at the end
of the 9 11 commission investigation
sure enough they come across this you
know super secret uh authorization for
the death of bin laden now it's
confusing again because it appears a few
months later bill clinton signed a
separate
intelligence finding for a separate
group of insurgents in afghanistan that
seemed to call off a kill operation but
at least for some period of time there
was an explicit order you can kill osama
bin laden now the strangest episode
about the clinton era does involve uh
clinton's national security adviser
sandy berger who uh in preparation for
uh i guess testifying or helping clinton
testify before
the commission goes to the national
archives starts looking through
documents in order to prepare and ends
up walking out of that building uh with
not just originals but i guess copies uh
uh he takes a lot of stuff what what
looking back on that he's pled guilty to
it he's i guess paid a fine um looking
back on that uh episode
what was he removing and why well as we
both know this has been a parlor game
for a long time why would sandy berger
do this crazy thing and start stealing
secret documents out of the national
archives especially crazy since
basically a lot of these documents made
sandy berger look pretty good that he'd
been one of the people in the in the
clinton white house who'd been most
insistent about going after al qaeda and
tracking it but it does appear that uh
during a period in 2002 and 2003 when
berger was acting as bill clinton's
representative to all the investigations
going on he went into the national
archives to review especially his old
files
and whenever he found a particular
document he would steal it
and this was a document a report that
had been prepared by dick clark the
counter-terrorism adviser uh in in 2000
after the millennium period during the
millennium it appeared that al qaeda was
about to attack they didn't
uh and uh berger asked clark to prepare
memos saying you know what have we
learned from this what can we do better
in the future and after action after
action
and clark does this and he comes up with
29 recommendations and
it appears that burger felt that this
document if it ever became public
would somehow implicate him scapegoat
him for 9 11 because there were some of
these
29 recommendations that hadn't been
acted on by the time the clinton
administration went out of business so
people could say well if you had acted
on this perhaps we would have had no
911. there are copies of this memo
throughout the the the files of the
intelligence agencies apparently and
where when berger finds it in the nsc
files he he takes a copy he slips it out
in his coat or in his socks or he gets
it out of the uh the archive somehow and
he also steals his own notes
his notes should have been classified it
should have been kept but he takes those
as well
but it appears again that he thought he
would be scapegoated if this document
ever saw the lie today i i know you
probably don't know the answer to this
but is it your sense about whether
burger was taking the document to simply
study it or to keep the investigators
from getting it well if he was doing it
to simply study it he wouldn't need five
copies of it he i say he steals it every
time he finds a copy of it he steals it
he knows he has copies of it back in his
in his office at one point because he's
previously stole them and then there's
this odd sequence where he goes back to
his office and actually shreds three of
them and puts in the the the the
he cuts it into pieces and puts the
pieces into his trash can before we
close on the uh the clinton uh era uh
how did the commission in the end treat
the clinton uh period uh
uh leading up to 911 and and
do you think that it was fair or unfair
well you know one thing we can talk
about is there aren't many judgments in
the report about the actions taken by
either administration but it does it
does record the fact that there was a
lot of that the people in the
administration sandy berger george tenet
to some extent richard clark were
obsessed uh during the clinton years
with bin laden uh and
there's also i think inherent criticism
that over those eight years they were
they were in office they weren't able to
end the al-qaeda threat bill clinton did
talk to the commission for
uh in testimony i guess in many hours
yes and was he's was he sworn and was it
did they learn anything that uh they
perhaps didn't know before then i don't
know i they he he uh has a i think a
four or five hour private session with
the commission he like president bush
was not required to be under oath which
apparently is not terribly surprising in
terms of the history of presidential
interrogations uh but apparently he he
really wows the the democrats and the
republicans with his detailed memory of
what went on during those years and i
think as i understand it uh the
republicans even more than the democrats
came out very impressed with with bill
clinton's explanation for what had
happened during his years in the white
house you tell a funny story in the book
about john lehman who apparently had
criticized bill clinton for years and
finally meeting him i'm not sure you can
repeat it i can't tell you repeat the
story but let's suffice to say that he
uh found clinton more uh impressive than
he expected absolutely no no
john layman uh apparently this is true
for president bush as well he was so
impressed that bill clinton had made
special efforts to know everybody's name
to know the names of all the
commissioners something about their
background even though he'd not met most
of them and john layman tells the story
of bill clinton who he's never met
before
you know calling out across the room
hello mr secretary how are you john
layman had been the navy secretary in
the reagan administration and
as if they were old friends and he goes
back and tells this to his wife and i
can't repeat the rest of the story but
his wife says you know john given what
you've said in the past about bill
clinton uh that's a surprising comment
well lives are important to keep
everybody in shape we're going to take a
break uh talking to phil shinnon about
his new book the commission the
uncensored history of the 9 11
investigation and we'll be back in a few
moments
afterwards and several other c-span
programs are available for download as
podcasts more with philip sheenan and
michael duffy in a moment
as executive producer of the washington
journal i know that viewer calls are an
important part of our on-air programming
it's part of who we are we're committed
to opening up the phone lines so you can
talk directly to journalists elected
officials and other decision makers we
began taking calls during the 1980
presidential campaign which made us the
first nationwide daytime call-in program
on television and ever since then we've
been inviting viewers to call in speak
and be heard we take calls each morning
on the washington journal during our
coverage of congress on the campaign
trail after important speeches and as a
part of our key event coverage our aim
is to hear from many different points of
view from across the political spectrum
so if you ever thought about calling in
and put it off we invite you to call in
and talk about our topic of the day
the c-span networks
providing you access to public affairs
on television
radio
and on the web
[Music]
afterwards with philip sheenan and
michael duffy continues
afterwards with philip sheenan and
michael duffy continues
welcome back afterwards our guest today
is phil sheenan of the new york times
the author of the new book the
commission the uncensored history of the
9 11 investigation uh welcome back uh i
i want to say this book is is written uh
in a wonderful fast-paced epistolary
style that i admire and it's just it's
architecture um it knows a lot to sort
of robert ludlum and helen mcginnis and
and i at several times reading phil i
thought i'm reading a teleplay for 24.
um tell us a little bit about uh how you
uh organ how you came up with the very
clever uh structure of this book i was
very worried because i was coming up i i
felt i had to have very short chapters
because i had this huge cast of
characters to deal with and i had to
take people from all over the world and
i thought you know if i don't if i don't
make these really short and discreet i'm
not going to get this done and i was
worried that you know short chapters
wouldn't be seen as serious book writing
um
my my publisher convinced me otherwise
uh but no that's that's the and i must
admit you know the way people live their
lives these days i don't think many
people have time to get much beyond a 10
page chapter sometimes and it's quite
satisfying when you do well i think
people were getting used to having their
information in shorter bursts absolutely
um tell us how long it took to write it
uh well of course i had the advantage of
having covered the commission for a
couple of years so i that you know i
considered that a lot of my research
period but no about a year's hard work
of writing and
take us a little bit behind the scenes
also how much access if you can talk
about did you have to all of the members
of the commission some probably were
helpful some probably weren't um how
open were the individual commemora
members apart from the chair of the two
chairman to uh telling the back story
did you how did you how did you read
that well some of them at this point are
almost friends because i came to know
them so well during the investigation
but no eight of the ten commissioners
gave me extensive interviews for the
book and many of them were very
forthcoming in a way they weren't
they didn't feel comfortable being
forthcoming earlier on uh and even the
two who didn't talk to me for the book
had you know communicated with me in the
past in one way or another um and uh
no as i said what was what was really
new and different in terms of the
reporting for the book was this instant
access to the or easy access to the
staff and they had the great stories to
tell right and you also talk to zelico
in a fashion absolutely he and i got to
praise him because he was
hugely forthcoming we he didn't want to
see me in person
um but he said he would answer my
questions by email and he was true to
his word and over months and months and
months he answered hundreds of questions
and i will note that all of the that
that questioning and answering is
available on the on the books website so
if people feel i'm being too tough on dr
zeliko they can judge for themselves how
how i treat him and what he has to say
for himself and and one of the things
that fascinates me in all blue ribbon
commissions is you have usually two
well-known powerful chairman but then
you have these commissioners whose roles
are sometimes less well-defined in in
the book you make clear that um each
commissioner's own role in his own way
or her own way um played important roles
but can you talk about
you know how they where they fit in the
orchestra a little bit uh in terms of
putting this together are they powerful
are they are they you know silent
companions are they people who only can
make a difference at the margins talk a
little bit about how those commissioners
fit into the final product what's a
different story for each commissioner
some of them were very involved to some
extent it's a factor of how much time
and energy they wanted to devote to the
commission
jamie gorelick the former number two
official justice department one of the
democratic commissioners was spent about
half her time working on commission
business during the course of the
investigation a couple of commissioners
were rarely seen at the commission's
offices and had very little to do with
the investigation in many ways but they
some of them took on their own
their own discrete investigations i
think richard ben beniste was very
interested in a particu set of a set of
subjects and he really bored in and
tried to understand them and
as the book explains you know he was
decisive in making sure that that
certain chapters were written in certain
ways
let's talk a little bit more about the
bush national security council now when
it came to the nsc during the early bush
years uh and the role that that white
house played in terms of anticipating uh
the al-qaeda attack much of the story
turns on whether you believe a man named
richard clark you mentioned that to us
he was a holdover from the clinton era
someone who
condelisa rice kept on also someone who
briefed her early on about the possible
dangers alkalia faced um and ironically
a holdover from the first bush
administration he worked in the uh for
the first president bush right
take us back to early 2001 a little bit
uh and and what role clark played in
trying to keep the pressure on the white
house about the possible threats from
tara that the commission reported clark
uh
so
dr rice comes in as the new national
security adviser and one of clark's
early responsibilities is to brief her
about what she needs to know about the
world and about terrorism
and apparently she they sit down for a
briefing and i should point out that
that philip zeliko apparently is in the
room as well and and berg and and
clark makes clear that he believes this
is the number one threat faced by the
national security threat faced by the
united states she needs to concentrate
on it and apparently at this meeting
sandy berger makes a special appearance
because he wants to get that point
across to her that this is what she
needs to worry about
despite that um it it does appear that
this is not of principal interest to dr
rice the new national security adviser
dick clark requests a very early meeting
with president bush
to discuss terrorist threats to discuss
al qaeda in particular and she rebuffs
him she says no you can do that as soon
as we've completed a broader review of
our counterterrorism policy a review
that would not be completed until
september of 2001. so the president's
principal counterterrorism aide is not
allowed to brief the president on
terrorism until you know eight months
nine months into the administration now
we know from the commission and even
before and and the book that uh george
tenet at the cia was quite concerned
during that summer
about all the signals that they were
receiving however they're unable they
were to process or collate them
but as the commission
sort of put the story the pieces back
together two years later
much of its discussion of the bush's
the bush white house role comes to rest
on a very secret document known as the
president's daily brief tell us a little
bit about the one prepared for august
6th sure well we should say the
president gets essentially a newspaper
every morning a super secret newspaper
prepared by the cia called the
president's daily very secret document
it has it has a readership of about four
or five i think six people perhaps now
um and essentially it's the hottest news
or the most important news overnight
gathered by the cia
and the
george tenet usually attends the
meetings in the morning where this
document is presented to the president
in in 2001. and it does appear that uh
on you know 40 times i believe in 2001
before 9 11 the president is told about
the al qaeda threat
and one of these documents in particular
presented to the president on august 6
2001 about a month before the attacks at
his texas ranch
was headlined bin laden determined to
strike in the u.s
and the you know that was a an explo the
the disclosure the preposition you said
was very important what became very
important over time that this was a
warning that al qaeda was going to
attack within american borders it might
use hijacked planes and it made
reference to the fact that there was
evidence to suggest that terrorists were
conducting surveillance of the skyline
of new york city
and yet it appears that uh not much was
done in response to this particular pdd
the strong suggestion uh uh
in looking at the evidence is that the
uh the nsc particularly uh condoleezza
rice should have
um
been more aggressive in getting the
president's attention is that a point
the commission made in its final report
no the commission really doesn't make
judgments of that sort it does lay out
the facts it does say that dick clark
you know requested a meeting that he uh
it has the long chronology of the
warning specific emails that clark sent
to rise but it makes no judgment as to
whether or not her actions were
appropriate or not this gets into the
the sort of subtitle of your book which
is it's the uncensored history of the 9
11 investigation talk
a little bit or tell us what you think
were the one or two most important
things that you imply were censored as a
consequence of the way that the
investigation was conducted or things
that were perhaps
more likely going over than it should
have been in the final result if you
read that if you read the 911 commission
report
and certainly as a reporter covering it
at the time as you were you weren't able
to make the statement that condoleezza
rice and the bush administration had
mishandled uh intelligence in 2001. or
for that matter that bill clinton had
handled or mishandled
intelligence properly during his tenure
it made no judgments it just said
in the case of of rice and clark it was
he said she said uh clark says this rice
that says clark says this rice says this
you know and dear reader we're not going
to tell you who's telling the truth when
in fact i think the staff of the
commission was pretty convinced that de
clarke was essentially telling the truth
and that the white house had largely
ignored a lot of the intelligence that
was right in front of it in the spring
and summer of 2001.
when the report comes out
it was roundly uh appraised
correct by both of our publications
i'm sure it sold millions of copies um
what made it unusually good if that was
a fair judgment
oh it was unusually good in the sense it
was the best written government report
of our lifetimes i mean it's it's a it's
a fine read and it and a lot of it
remains to this day the definitive
history of 9 11 and what happened on the
morning of 9 11.
um
and in terms of some of it you know some
of its recommendations were probably
good ones and many of them have been
acted on and it's a remarkable thing
that in this partially partisan time
you've got five democrats and five
republicans to come together in
agreement on you know central national
security issues um i don't i i don't
think people so it might there is much
to be praised in the 911 commission
report but i think the problem is that
you know as as the book reports my book
reports that they did appear it does
appear they missed a lot
um if you were going to uh
add um
well let's talk about some of the things
they missed late in the fairly late in
the investigation you report that they
some members of the investigative team
had gone over to an office i believe on
k street to look at some files uh from
the national security agency the
electronic snooping agency out in fort
meade maryland what happened and what
did they find there
well you know early on in the process
the nsa you know which is in terms of
budget the largest spy agency in the
government uh offered up its archives on
on terrorism and al qaeda and you know
most of the raw material used in the
federal government on terrorism used
to detect terrorist threats comes from
the nsa from its spy satellites and it's
ease dropping on the ground
and again it offered up its archives
early on to the 911 commission but
for a variety of reasons the 911
commission just didn't seem terribly
interested in going to read through it
it may have something to do with the
fact that fort meade is a bit further
out of town than langley virginia where
the cia is located
one staff member really valiantly tries
to get tries to to do this herself right
she knows the nsa she knows how valuable
those archives are and she takes on the
responsibility of trying to review this
huge archives all by herself
and towards the end of the investigation
she finds some pretty explosive material
in these archives and she alerts her
colleagues and they have this frantic
weekend trip to fort meade to try to
find what they've missed but in many
ways it's too late there's just no more
time left and this material i think it's
worth spending another
minute on is about iran and the
connections between some of the
hijackers uh and uh and at least transit
points uh through iran what did that
mean at least what did that possibly
suggest as they head to conclusion in
the i guess spring and summer of 2004.
what's remarkable for a year and a half
washington had been obsessed by this
question of what was there a connection
between al qaeda and saddam hussein al
qaeda and iraq
and this researcher goes into the nsa
archives and finds that actually there's
a lot of material suggesting that there
might be a much closer relationship
between some of the 911 hijackers and
officials of the government of iran
and hezbollah the the militant group in
lebanon that's tied into the iranian
government and it appears that iranian
officials may have offered very
important logistical support to some of
the the 911 hijackers
um you know they realize this is very
sensitive
explosive material and they frantically
go up to fort meade to try to get the
rest of it and they force into the final
report of the 911 commission really on
the eve of publication some of this
material and indeed some of it is found
in the final report of the commission is
there any uh evidence that the
anyone
after the commission finish to work went
back and tried to look at all
uh the stuff that the nsa had about uh
because it's not clear that that had
ever been looked at before no i and i
don't have any sense that anybody since
gone back to look would it have been a
uh impossible for them to keep going or
were they up against a tight deadline at
the time was their time was up gotcha um
in recent days the commissioners and in
a separate statement some senior staff
on the commission have disputed the
notion um that you suggest in the book
imply in the book that zelico used his
position to to to steer or tilt the
commission's findings a statement i
think you also these statements i think
are also available on your website
posted them all um but is that what you
were suggesting in the book
and he was tilting or steering the
findings you know it's funny one of the
things i've had to battle against in
terms of the perception of the book is
um
the bits and pieces of this book leaked
out ahead of its publication and if you
read some of the bloggers accounts and
some of the internet accounts it will
sound like i have said the 911
commission was a whitewash engineered by
philip zeliko and karl rove and no it
doesn't the book doesn't say that uh but
it does say that philip zeliko had
there was at least the appearance of
some remarkable conflicts of interest
some of these and some of these
conflicts i don't believe were well
known to the commissioners when they
hired him and maybe not even well no to
them when the commission went out of
business and i think uh there are
certainly people on the staff who
believe that did influence the way the
investigation was conducted
and the way uh judgments or or lack of
judgments are made about certain
individuals in the clinton and bush
administrations the the book also makes
clear that there were some people on the
staff who were worried about telephone
calls between zelico and karl rove
during the life of the commission but we
don't really know what those phone calls
were about we don't we absolutely don't
all i can tell you though is that you
know zelico's uh
contact his his friendship with many
people in the white house was well known
at the beginning of the investigation
and zelico had promised that he was
going to avoid even the appearance of
conflict of interest and cut out you
know all but essential communications
with his friends and former colleagues
in the bush administration and then in
june 2003 the phone rings in zelico's
office and the secretary picks up the
phone and it's karl rove
now karl rove what what reason is there
for the president's chief political
operative to be calling the chairman of
the 911 commission who's already under
suspicion because of his ties to the
white house the director now i'm sorry
yes
and this and he called and wrote calls
again the next day and he calls again a
few more times a couple more times in
september
and the fact that zelico's having
communication with roe becomes known on
the staff and there's huge suspicion you
know what what is going on now again
zelico and the white house say this is
completely innocent and involves
zelico's old work at the university of
virginia and there may be a good reason
for zelico and rogue to have contacts
but
again it's an appearance problem and the
staff thought it was not appropriate for
philip zeliko to be talking with
somebody like karl rove were you able to
ask grover is that look at what those
calls were about or what was that was
the they said they were innocent they
involved the university of virginia
business and how can i just follow up
this there is the the submission also
grows though when zelico apparently
calls in his secretary shortly
thereafter and closes the door and
apparently informs her that she's no
longer to keep a log of his telephone
contacts with the white house and that
adds to the suspicion were kanan
hamilton aware of this uh concern among
the staff as the commission near the end
of its its life in a general sense yes
on the rove material i don't believe
they were aware of it at all we were
able to talk to them after you completed
your uh your most of your reporting for
the book and asked them how they were
wrestled with
these cross pressures these political
very partisan feelings really on both
sides uh about uh zelico and his role as
executive director and how did they
weigh this in their own
you know sure no i talked to them during
the course of the investigation and i
certainly talked to them in detail
afterwards they are you know two very
experienced politicians and they've
dealt with difficult
um
you know partisan people all their
professional lives and they thought if
zelico got out of hand somehow they
would be able to rein him in um
and
i think there are probably instances
when they did right
bipartisan commissions are designed
you know probably by bipartisan
commissions
they're almost designed to be flawed um
uh are there just natural uh sort of
shortcomings when you put an equal
number of people from two parties in a
in a uh in a very partisan edge together
to try to ask them to solve a problem
absolutely absolutely and that's why you
tend to get pretty homogenized reports
uh you know i've certainly heard it
argued that maybe the better
contribution for the 911 commission
would have been a very
strongly worded majority report and a
very strongly worded minority report
that might have a lot more of the detail
to to get to the public uh but
overall i i you know it's hard to deny
that the general public reaction of this
report was one of what a miraculous
thing it is that five republicans and
five democrats can agree on anything who
drafted the report in the end
mostly the staff
the staff had produced internal reports
over time and they were brought together
to make the final report i know the
commissioners the 10 commissioners feel
some
point of pride about authorship and i
you know there are passages they
certainly wrote the overall work that
was written mostly by the staff and were
there last-minute fights at the
commission office the way there are i
know in magazine offices and
occasionally newspaper offices about the
exact wording of certain parts
absolutely any that are important well
again going back to dr zeliko there was
one there were a couple of real battles
at the end about how certain things
would be portrayed
and you know one thing that dr zeliko is
quite insistent come out of the final
report is a passage that had been
written by the staff that was going to
weigh
how often president bush and president
clinton address terrorism issues
publicly
the research showed that president
clinton often talked publicly about
terrorist threats and about al qaeda in
particular and that president bush both
on the campaign trail in 2000 and in the
white house in 2001 almost never talked
about it and uh at zelico's insistence
that material came out and you know that
i think that would have come about as
close to direct criticism of george bush
as anything that would have been found
in the commission's final report and
again it's left on the editing room
floor the book doesn't really touch on
this but one of the most important
things to come out of the commission
were a series of recommendations about
things that did need to be fixed things
that needed to be changed they were
probably my memory is going to fade here
but that seems to me there were a half
dozen to a dozen or maybe there were
seven there were there were
can you talk a little bit about
if you know this um
whether any or all of those have
actually been enacted changed
to the commission's credit i think the
majority of their recommendations have
been enacted in one way or another uh
into law uh the most important change
they recommended was the creation of the
post of director of national
intelligence some sort of you know super
spy to to connect the dots to make sure
all the spy agencies are working
together and i think it's i don't think
anybody else really knows if that
operation is
really solve the problems or whether or
not it's just added in another layer
bureaucracy but indeed that that that
job was created at the recommendation of
the 911 commission you have a wonderful
line uh in the in in one of the chapters
later on in the book about how i think
it's george tenet lost bob mueller one
right uh that's not a personal judgment
that's a bureaucratic judgment i think
as much as anything else talk about how
the how the how
i guess events following the
commission's report have affected those
two agencies it probably spoke personal
and bureaucratic but um uh you know
mueller through this lobbying effort was
able to keep the fbi intact at the end
of the day the 911 commission really
gave the fbi you know largely a pass it
had been under pressure by some at the
time to be busted up there were there
were members of the commission who came
onto the commission absolutely believing
that the fbi should be broken up that it
was just a dysfunctional agency to the
extreme uh but again mueller was so
effective that it was he he's often
described as the man who saved the fbi
and i think that's an appropriate that's
a that's an accurate description um
tenant laws before going to tennessee do
we know uh anything more um four or five
i guess one two three four years later
about whether the fbi is really a
different place in 2008 than it was in
2001 i i think if you talk to a lot of
the commissioners they will say at the
end of the day they're hugely
disappointed with
the changes that director mueller has
made that that much of what they were
promised has not come to pass so he
avoided the re the the huge government
makeover but it's not clear that the
institution has changed exactly and i
think i i think the commissioners feel
they were not misled so much by mueller
as they were misled by the institution
of the fbi that the reforms that were
supposedly being made were really not
being made i'm sorry now on to the cia
if if mueller won that bureaucratic you
know skirmish what happened at this uni
well you mentioned the dni the dna well
you know but previously there had been
the director of central intelligence the
last occupant of that job was george
tennant and uh he in that role tenants
supposedly had oversight over all the
spy agencies in the government and one
of the central findings of the 911
commission was that that didn't work
and that job needed to be essentially
tenant's job needed to be eliminated and
replaced by director of national
intelligence and a cia director somebody
who would just be responsible for the
cia and that came to pass
but it's hard for us to know yet as you
hinted whether that has resulted in a
more
fleet-footed
uh
multi-uh you know where an intelligence
operation that is more engaged with
itself than it was before absolutely and
i you know i say a lot of people
concerned is just another layer of
bureaucracy right um and what happened
to phil zellico
he uh well
uh the commission goes out of business
in august
2004
president bush is re-elected in november
2004 he quickly removes colin powell as
secretary of state replaces her with
condoleezza rice
and she quickly sets in place her new
team at the state department and names
philip zeliko as her sort of all-purpose
counselor he'll be
he'll have her ear on all major national
security issues do you think that was a
reward
i wouldn't say that there are certainly
others who might did he stay very long
he didn't he actually was gone i think
he's now returned in recent months to
the university of virginia where he's
got a tenured job at the in the history
department
and
looking back on the commission one of
the difficult things i think about
writing about this then and i'm sure
you're encountering writing a book is
that there are a lot of people who are
sort of amateur experts on on 9 11 that
you encounter um
you agree that this document remains
this the most definitive account of what
happened
both of them but no on many issues the
911 commission report is the definitive
account why does why does that event
create so many and now that you're
steeped and double steeped in the
history of both the event itself and the
investigation that followed why has it
created such a
you know small minor industry in
conspiracy theories well you know it's
it's like the canada and you have to be
careful what you say here because oh
listen i i've learned too well but no
it's like the kennedy assassination is
just
when a national tragedy strikes this
country there just tends to be a
community that forms that wants to offer
an alternative explanation it does
demonstrate the huge amount of cynicism
about the actions of the federal
government uh but no i mean my book has
been uh harshly criticized by people who
believe that 9 11
a large number of people who believe
that 9 11 was some sort of inside job
that this is actually the bush
administration that carried out the
attacks i think um
uh i think the book my book makes clear
that actually incompetence may be a more
prominent uh explanation for for why 9
11 happened and uh kanan hamilton
looking back on this experience from a
distance of a couple of years how do
they feel as far as you know about
both what they did and what has happened
as a result of the
of the and the families i guess i want
to know about the families how they feel
about the recommendations and and the
overall product that was created well
kane and hamilton i think still have a
huge amount of pride in what they
accomplished here and again i think they
have as much pride over the fact that
they could demonstrate bipartisanship in
washington as over anything else
the families the families it's a mixed
response i mean many people many
families have seized upon my book as uh
as explaining why there needs to be some
sort of additional investigation of 9
11. uh you know many of them believe
they never got all the answers about why
their loved ones were murdered and
they're still pressing for that
explanation
now i have to you have to take off your
hat as a reporter and a journalist for
the new york times and put it on as a as
an author of the definitive text and
that is looking back do you think that
the commission should have gone further
in in naming names pointing fingers
saying here's here are the people who
you know dropped the ball would that
have been the right thing to do
uh i do think that the 911 commission by
producing a final report as it did
essentially endorsed the concept of no
fault government
and i think you and
you and i make our livings in washington
proving that actually there are human
beings who do make big mistakes and
should be held accountable for them you
know it is a remarkable thing that all
these years later not one person has
been fired not one person has been
demoted as a result of their bungling of
their jobs before 9 11 when i think the
record is very clear that people did
bungle their jobs and not only were
these people not punished for it some of
them have been promoted as a result of
it and i i don't know if that's
necessarily a good thing for the
government
if we ever i hope we don't but if we
ever have a need to have another
investigation of this size about this
kind of thing
would you recommend that we go down that
road or take the approach that kane and
hamilton did and saying let's just
figure out what went wrong i think the
most interesting idea i've heard
certainly as a result of my book is that
you know what you need is you need a
bunch of scholars you need a bunch of
engineers you need some scientists you
need people who have absolutely no
connection to washington nothing to do
with politics and let them try to figure
it out much as was done like with the
challenger disaster you bring in and
experts people who really know this
stuff and let them go at it that might
be a way of of of removing these
conflicts of interest questions that
that so pervade um this this
investigation thank you phil and thank
you for watching we've been joined today
by phil sheenan of the new york times
the author of the wonderful new book the
commission the uncensored history of the
9 11 investigation it's literally a book
i could not put down uh and i enjoyed it
it's thorough i learned things having
covered uh that commission that i did
not know or maybe i just forgot but i
think i didn't know them
so
thank you for joining us and thank you
as well
[Music]